hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
cm.l2-3.4.3 track review approve or
disapprove and log changes to
organizational systems let's find out
what this exciting control is about
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor is
feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
trying to understand all this cmmc dfars
and nist SP Hunter 101 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in cmfc control
cm.l2-3.4.3 track review approve or
disapprove and log changes to
organizational systems what we're
talking about here is the idea of
showing assessors how you are tracking
approving and denying changes in the
system as they happen Okay so in other
words it's not good enough to just sort
of have you know changes to the system
when it comes to security sort of just
like spoken to one another unless you're
like a three or four person company uh
but you know ultimately what they're
looking for is we want to see the
process for change in your organization
so another way of putting this is you
can demonstrate the decision-making
process and show that unauthorized
system changes actually cannot happen
without approval so again it's all about
making sure that the checks and balances
are in place especially when it comes to
security so obviously an unapproved
system change is not a good thing and in
smaller networks maybe this is not quite
such a big deal but in larger networks
as they say multiple Cooks in the
kitchen can make a super messy cake
we could have done better than that I
don't know we we could have had some
more fun with that than a cake
I don't know
I got nothing maybe we couldn't have
maybe we couldn't have come up with a
better joke
I'm gonna fire the writer anyway
so there has to be a defined process in
procedure I'm the right I know I wrote
that one I wrote it it was late at night
I was
a long night it's a really long night
can you tell all right uh so there has
to be a defined process and procedures
for doing this let's check out what the
assessors are looking for and how to
make them happy
so four things you're looking for
determine if changes to the system are
tracked uh so how do we how do we do
that right well you know
again most organizations have something
like a ticketing system
um
I don't know if I'd really feel
comfortable saying hey you know we track
this stuff via email emails kind of you
know not the best or effective way of
really tracking things it is a way uh
I'll be honest with you know we use a
ticketing system I haven't had any my
clients really go through a dipcac or
dcma audit
um you know who they're all on a
ticketing system so that's how we answer
I suppose you could do a via email but
it might be a little bit risky it might
be kind of a little uh if you're really
really small maybe you could get away
with email but you really need a system
for doing this second assessment Point
determine if changes to the system are
reviewed so are all changes are reviewed
and commented on Via the it ticketing
system here's an example from that one
somebody should be a reviewer or a
manager of the people who are doing the
actual changes right so again if you're
really really small it's a little
different but if you're if you're a
typical mid to large size business uh
again generally speaking in your systems
you're going to have someone who's
assigned to be a manager or a role
leader and they want to know there are
certain things that people can't do
without an approval and that's part of
especially when it comes to security
third assessment Point determine if
changes to the system are approved or
disapproved changes to the system are
tracked in the I.T ticketing system
determination on approval or disapproval
are kept within the ticket so again
we're going to see in the service ticket
or in the email chain that a manager
comes in says yes this is okay and then
they take it back and then the doer uh
you know sort of the the the maybe it's
an I.T technician or whoever it is is
actually executing the change in the
system they'll go make the change uh but
again someone's got to be acting to
approve that
fourth assessment Point determine if
changes to the system are logged so yes
we want to log changes that happen to
the system again all covered in the I.T
technique system but it could also be
taken care of in your seam system or
your security information event
management system again somehow you've
got to actually demonstrate to an
assessor that when things change they're
being tracked and uh and logged more
importantly again somehow there's an
ability to find out what happened when
and Trace that back over time
now if you are reading this or or shall
I say following along with me on our
Awesome YouTube channel and you are
banging your head against the wall
thinking yourself how am I going to
listen to the next 37 hours of Mike
talking to me about this amazingly
brilliant subject matter and you are
thinking to yourself I think I'm in over
my head the good news is we work with
people just like you all day long all
week long even we work with defense
contractors who really are just like you
okay supply chain defense contractors if
you even know about this stuff if you
even found my video you're probably the
people we help all right we help them
when this defars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff has been dropped into
their lap like a seagull on a sunny day
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance as your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that is
what becoming an on call compliance hero
can do for you my friends
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better hope smash that subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance
centers roll it out until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]
anyway